[MUSIC PLAYING]
TUAN NGUYEN: Thank
you, everyone,
for showing up this morning
on the very last day.
Hopefully, you've
had a great week.
We're here to talk
about supporting
enterprise applications with
production-grade Kubernetes.
And this is a conversation
about the infrastructure
or the Kubernetes-- on-demand
Kubernetes as a platform,
and not necessarily about the
applications themselves, OK?
So hopefully, you
were expecting that.
My name is Tuan Nguyen.
I'm a technical marketing
engineer for Cisco.
I've been with
Cisco for two years.
I was actually a transplant
from an acquisition
that was Clicker Technologies
and is now Cisco Cloud Center.
OK, so we're going to go
through a product overview.
The product itself is called
Cisco Container Platform.
You may have heard of it.
Heretofore, it will be
CCP because I don't want
to say the long name, right?
So Cisco Container
Platform, CCP--
we'll go through the
product overview.
We'll address some
of the challenges
with production-grade
Kubernetes and how
we're solving for those
challenges, especially
around storage and networking.
And then, we'll talk a little
bit about the Hybrid Cloud
Platform that was
announced or you
may have heard about
this week, and some
of the inherent benefits of
that reference architecture.
OK, so the premise of
Cisco Container Platform
is really to provide
IT or the enterprise
with a production-grade
turnkey solution for consuming
Kubernetes, OK?
So some of the challenges
with Kubernetes is automation,
its consistency, it's--
integrating it into the entirety
of the enterprise ecosystem.
And so what we're doing
is we're taking code
from upstream Kubernetes, right?
I'll explain a little
bit about that.
And we're making it easily
deployable, easily consumable,
right?
And what we're
really designing for
is a consistent
environment for Kubernetes
across different clouds.
So it could be on-prem
as well as X cloud,
whoever the cloud is.
I'll talk about the
partnership that we
have with Google and
some of the integrations
that we've already
built into the platform.
But for us, we want to
design a platform that
is hybrid cloud optimized,
and I'll talk about that.
We'll talk about the
integration between Kubernetes,
our version of Kubernetes,
and the ecosystem.
And then, we'll talk about the
different deployment models.
So today, we have
integration into VMware
because really, it's the most
pervasive of the hypervisors.
We spent quite a
number of conversations
with our customers, and we
were counseled and advised
that really, the
need of the hour
is for us to
deliver a Kubernetes
platform on VMs, right?
In the future, we'll
have integration
into OpenStack as well
as bare metal workloads.
OK, so one of the ways that
we differentiate ourselves
is that we make it
easy for Kubernetes
to integrate into
the IaaS, right?
So for us, we have
best-of-breed products--
hardware and software--
around SDN, core and data center
networking, VPN networking,
and then, of
course, storage with
our hyperconverged solution.
So we already have an IaaS layer
that we've helped our customers
to design, and then
now, what we're
putting on top of that is a
Kubernetes environment that
integrates into the
existing IaaS, OK?
So a little bit
more about that--
100% upstream, we see our
opportunity in innovation,
not so much in
modifying the native API
and code of Kubernetes.
But the innovation for us
is to encompass Kubernetes
into the ecosystem
that is existing
today in the enterprise.
And so for us, it'll be easy for
us to deliver to you with speed
and scale the new
versions of CCP
whenever a Kubernetes
version changes.
So if we're not doing
anything with upstream code,
it'll be easy for us to
deliver to you faster, right?
And then, we're also
curating that version,
which means that we're
putting it through a QA cycle
and testing and validation
and making sure that when
it hits your data
center that it's
going to be something
that is consistently
dependable across the platform.
So speaking about the
integration and about IT
consistency, we're covering the
day one, day two operations,
right?
So insofar as we're
talking about setup,
the deployment of the platform
itself is software delivered.
It's an OVA.
You just import it into vCenter.
This is something that is
known to most IT operations.
And then layering on three
different options for a CNI,
which is a Container
Network Interface--
we'll go through
that a little bit.
But from setup to consumption
to integration and management,
I'll show you how we allow
users to self-service and deploy
clusters from a management
portal, and then also,
how we add day two operations
into a catalog into Cloud
Center, which is--
Cloud Center is not
a component of CCP,
but it is kind of a
centralized catalog
for multi-cloud deployment.
OK, so CCP itself--
Container Platform--
did GA in early May.
And previous to that, we went
through an EAP cycle, which
is an Early Access Program.
I'm going to explain
one of the use cases
that we've been highlighting
because it really is the use
case that we are solving for.
But we did go through
an EAP program
through four or five
months, and then we
have a pretty aggressive
roadmap for the remainder
of the year, one of
which is obviously
to integrate into bare metal
and also to onboard more
environments like OpenStack.
OK, so from an abstraction
layer, what you're getting
is a control plane and
a data plane, right?
So the data plane is
the multi-tenancy layer,
which really means
that different users
from different business groups
or different development teams
can go to the interface
of the control plane
to deploy their own tenants, OK?
So the tenants are color-coded
by blue and green, right?
So you can see that there's
kind of a separation as far
as the default services
that run on the tenants
as well as services that
run on the control plane.
So the control plane
itself runs Kubernetes,
so it's kind of like Kubernetes
deploying Kubernetes, right?
And below that
abstraction layer is just
the physical layer,
which is the storage,
the hypervisor, the networking.
So we, very similar to a lot
of solutions in the industry,
are using Prometheus
for monitoring,
Kibana as ELK stack.
And then, we're
also using Grafana
to visualize some of the
performance monitoring
for Kubernetes.
So architecturally,
and both from a logical
and a physical perspective, it
would look like this, right?
So you will have--
HX stands for HyperFlex.
So those basically would
be your compute nodes.
So on your compute
nodes, if you have
a cluster of three compute
nodes, you would have compute,
and then you would have VMs
that run the control plane that
would be the blue VMs, right?
So the blue VMs obviously would
have the same connectivity
into, let's say, your
storage, your layer 3 network,
your core networking.
All of those things apply.
And then you have the green,
which represents the tenant
nodes or tenant clusters.
Those are also VMs, right?
And of course, you can have a
one-to-many, meaning many VMs
operating on one physical
node, which is the HX server.
And then, of course,
what we're showing here
is that it's a well-connected
stack, whether you're
talking about the physical or
the virtualized environment,
right?
And it's self-enclosed.
It has access to a 10 to 40-gig
bandwidth on the network layer,
right?
And then upstream, you can--
well, and you can do underlay
or overlay from a Kubernetes
cluster point of view.
And then, of course,
it will integrate
into your upstream layer 3
or L3 [INAUDIBLE] gateways.
Hopefully, that makes sense.
So one thing about the PGs,
which stands for Port Group,
and VLANs--
these are not affixed, right?
So these are not static.
They're just examples of how
things would be connected
and how they would be configured
across the entire stack.
OK, so integrating
into the enterprise
requires a few things
related to RBAC, right?
So we know that our
consumers, our developers
are different than
our operators,
and within the
platform, we have a way
to give those personas
the privilege to do
what they need to do, right?
So developers usually
don't really--
they're not incentivized
to understand how
to deliver the service, right?
They just want to
consume it, which
is the Kubernetes side, right?
And so IT admins have
a different awareness
or a different interest.
That's to deliver the service
levels to the platform
so that it can be consistent and
it could be highly available,
right?
So from the point of view of
the IT admin or the consumer
or the service designer
or the DevOps operator
or whoever it is,
we've got coverage
for the day one,
day two operations
as well as the
different personas that
are interested in the
type of responsibilities.
OK, and then I mentioned that
this is deployed through VMware
today.
So we also chose that
because really, this
is an easy, kind of
non-friction, seamless way
for IT operators today to
adopt Kubernetes, right?
That's really the strategy
behind the integration
with VMware.
OK, and then this is
really my three screens
to deploy a Kubernetes
story, right?
So this is the first screen
in creating a cluster.
These are the different
options for the second screen.
I'm going to go through a demo.
Hopefully, I'll have
the time for that.
And the third screen is
basically submission.
So what you see
here is the ability
to name it, to inject a key
that is known to the development
team, different
attributes about VMware--
so data store, network,
port group, the image,
name, things like that, and
then the size of the cluster.
So one thing about this is
that once this is deployed,
there are several
things that the user can
do based on roles to
either scale out or scale
in this cluster, right?
So one of the things that we're
adding into the feature set
is the ability for the
platform to autoscale itself.
OK, so now we're going
to talk about storage,
and we're going to
address specifically
why HyperFlex, the
hyperconverged platform
that Cisco sells, is
important in this relationship
with Kubernetes, right?
So you probably are aware that
within Kubernetes, there's
kind of a native driver
approach to provisioning
PVs or Persistent Volumes,
which means that you can
use the basic native driver.
It's nothing fancy.
It just delivers a
volume to the containers.
But if you need to deliver a
high I/O persistent volume that
also can have some
special attributes,
then you'd move into the
FlexVolume framework, right?
So this FlexVolume
framework allows
manufacturers to create
their own specialized plugins
for Kubernetes.
So that all just described
the FlexVolume driver that
is specific to the HX platform.
OK, and then I'm going to
go through how it actually
works, although I'm
not going to really go
through the deep dive, right?
This is just-- for instance,
if you have an ESX server--
that's the middle
green layer, right?
So by default, the
abstraction layer of HX
allows for NFS data stores to
be presented to ESX servers, OK?
Now that is just
typical shared storage.
The VMs that are deployed
through CCP, which are
the Kubernetes cluster nodes--
they can both access
the NFS, which
is just file storage or
shared volumes, and then
they can also, via
iSCSI, via the IO Visor--
they can access iSCSI volumes.
Now, the important thing about
them accessing iSCSI volumes
is you are mounting an I/O
level volume to the container
so that the container can-- it's
a block level device, right?
So the container can
actually format that volume
and can do special things to it.
And the benefit--
yeah, so the benefit
is that on HX, because
it is hyperconverged,
the blocks of storage get stored
onto different servers, right?
This is very basic to how HX
delivers a storage replication,
right?
And then, of course, it also
automatically replicates--
you don't have to do this--
the blocks of storage
on different nodes.
So it creates a redundancy
so that if one node fails
or if one ESX server fails,
then Kubernetes will bring up
the containers, obviously.
And then, the
containers will also
be remapped to their volumes.
OK, so the benefits of
doing this with HX and CCP
is that you'll be able to apply
some data retention policies,
data protection policies.
And of course, you've got
automatic replication,
so that's inherent
within the platform,
and it's something that
is native to Kubernetes.
You don't have to
do anything special.
You won't have to install
special drivers because
of the integration with CCP.
A CCP node will automatically
have the FlexVolume driver
installed every time you deploy
the tenant cluster from CCP.
And then, from a
networking perspective,
there are many different
options, underlay,
overlay options when you
talk about Kubernetes.
Not all of these options
are standardized.
Some of them are pervasive
across the different clouds,
but the unified approach
to policy design, policy
enforcement is one of the
challenges, and certainly
a challenge that we
are solving with CCP.
So there are three options for
CNIs when you talk about CCP.
I'm going to go into the
first and the second option.
The third option is Calico.
That's the pervasive one.
You can find it on GKE.
You can find it on
AKS and EKS also.
So it's something
that certainly you
can do research on your own.
The first two are the ones
that I'll dive deep into.
So if you aren't
familiar with ACI,
ACI is our Application-Centric
Infrastructure,
which is really just a fancy
name for an SDN solution
that is both hardware
and software.
So what I'm describing
is the ability for, let's
say, a network administrator
or a network operator
to design policies that can
be enforced by the software
or by the hardware, right?
So it's designed in software,
applied at hardware,
and it's effective to
east-west communication, right?
So north-south--
east-west is really
where microservices
need protection,
and ACI is that for both
microservices and VM-based
deployments.
So this is OVS based.
I believe that it's a
derivative of OpenDaylight.
Cisco has had some integration
with OVS in the past.
This integration-- the
ACI-CNI integration--
is a little different, but
there are certain steps
to do this if you had a
Kubernetes cluster that was not
deployed by CCP.
So you have the ability
to do this on your own
if you have Kubernetes and ACI.
What CCP is doing
is it is automating
all of the integration
points for you.
So there are a few
things that you
have to enter into
configurations,
and then there is YAML
files that you have to bind.
The CCP integration will do
all of that automatically,
and it's beneficial to both the
application architects as well
as the network administrators
because it's dynamic, right?
It automatically
protects the pods
that are running in the fabric.
There are three different
models of protection.
So the default model
is a cluster isolation,
which means that if
you've got a pod subnet,
all of the pods
across the clusters
are protected as
one entity, right?
So in ACI, it's called an
EPG or an End Point Group.
The pods would just be
considered endpoints, right?
And then, they
would be protected
as one, singular unit
inside the cluster.
There's also-- if you
wanted to annotate
the different
namespaces, then you
could accomplish a
namespace isolation,
which is not a cluster-wide.
Then it would be a
kind of separation
at the namespace layer, which
is pretty unique when you think
about it because things
that operate inside
of a namespace or microservices
that are running inside
of a namespace can be
protected both from each other
as far as the workloads, and
then from other namespaces,
right?
So this is treating
pods as endpoints
on the network fabric.
And then, of course,
you can go as granular
as protecting the
deployments themselves.
So each deployment, each
replica of the deployment
would be protected by other
services in the deployment.
So that's very, very granular.
And then, ACI, from a
visualization construct,
makes it easy for
network administrators
to see what is happening
and to also operate
the things that
may be a little bit
difficult for the application
developers to express, right?
So we don't expect
application developers
to understand the
network fabric the way
that a network
administrator would, right?
But if there's a way for us to
visualize it, which there is--
a way for us to
visualize the filters
and the different contracts
and the relationship
that we establish
in ACI between what
we call the consumer
and the provider,
which is source and
destination, then
we make it easy for the teams to
collaborate and to troubleshoot
in one of those firestorms.
OK, so one of the other CNI
options, probably something
you may have heard of--
it's really a
networking platform
that is utilized by
service providers.
It's called Contiv.
It's open source, and it's been
inside of Cisco for a while.
Our service provider
customers use it,
but it's basically a user space.
It's a networking platform
that bypasses the kernel,
uses the user space, which means
that it depends on the driver
in order to propagate bandwidth
across the different nodes,
right?
So it's optimized because it's
not serial packet processing.
It's vector packet
processing, and it's something
that you can
probably get a deeper
dive in if you're tied to
a Cisco account or a Cisco
engineer.
It's, I think, a very
intuitive way to deal
with container networking.
OK, so we have a plan to
really follow the release
cycle of Kubernetes itself.
So we expect that
every major release--
1 to 2, 2 to 3--
is going to be very aligned
to Kubernetes release cycles.
We're planning on
that to be quarterly,
patching upgrades, which is
X.X, is going to be on demand.
And then minor releases
will be monthly.
So we have right now a 1.3
that was just released.
1.4 will come out next month.
2.0 will come out
the next quarter.
So that's kind of our
plan for release cycles.
OK, and then obviously, we'll
have a compatibility matrix
of the different
parts of the ecosystem
that we're going
to integrate into,
which is a great segue into
the Hybrid Cloud Platform.
You may have heard about this.
You may have also heard
about the GKE On-Prem.
So the thing that we
are really focused on
as far as the Hybrid Cloud
Platform is the hybrid cloud
deployment and lifecycle
management, right?
So we know that
there are new roles--
DevOps, service
designers, people
who work on modeling
their consumption.
All those different roles and
different responsibilities--
they need to come
into a tool or a tool
set that they can
all relate to, right?
So all of their
roles are converging.
And of course, the environments
are expanding and also getting
more complex, especially when
you talk about integrating
those different environments.
So the way that I've been
describing the Hyper Cloud
Platform is it is a reference
architecture, right?
So it's very much like FlexPod,
if you've heard about FlexPods
in the past.
It's something that you
could build yourself.
What we're doing is we are
building it, integrating it,
and maintaining the
compatibility matrix for you,
right?
So we're developing
best practices.
What this is is a
reference architecture that
gets validated designs, that
gets updated every quarter,
that you can either use the
validated design to build it
out yourself in a few
months, or if you wanted
to engage a partner, we've
got plenty of partners
that have worked with us.
And we've also run an EAP--
an Early Access Program--
for this very architecture.
So what that means is that
in the past several months,
we've placed this
architecture-- so rack and stack
and configuration-- into
data centers for eight
of our strategic
partners, right?
And then we've had them go
through workbook exercises
and validate the solution
stack as well as the use cases
that we're solving, right?
So this has already gone
through validation cycles.
I'd say that we're onto our
second phase of the validation.
But the reference
architecture is
going to provide to you
a consistent environment
and a consistent
model for deploying
as well as for
designing policies
and governance for both
the enterprise as well
as the public cloud.
OK, and then this is
one of the customers
that we've worked
very closely with.
So I'm sure that all of
you have heard about SAP.
They have a heritage in
data warehousing on prem.
They were seeing
that data definitely
was being distributed,
especially IoT data or sensor
data that was being
processed by ML, or Machine
Learning, or just big
data in the cloud, right?
So there was a preferential
treatment for customer or sales
data that had to exist on prem.
And then, of course, it
needed to be integrated
with IoT data that existed, of
course, on the public cloud--
in the public cloud.
And so they created
this data hub,
which basically has a serverless
data pipelining component
to the framework.
And then it has a
runtime that has
to be delivered near
where the data is.
So that's kind of a
short summary of what
they were doing with data hub.
But the reason
why they partnered
with us is because
the data hub and then
the framework for
the data hub needed
to run on Kubernetes, right?
And so Kubernetes-- the data
hub itself needed to be on prem,
and we delivered CCP for
them to meet this demand.
And so you can see that they
chose Kubernetes because one,
containers can be pervasive
across the different cloud
platforms.
And that's their
approach, is they
need interconnectivity between
the different cloud targets,
right?
And they need a way to
provide secure transport
as well as just connectivity
and overall policy for the pods
that run.
OK, still time to visit
us at the Cisco booth,
and then many ways for
you to engage with us.
I'm going to have time for
a demo, so it's very good.
And then, I don't know if
you heard about the Cloud
Challenge, right?
So if you are a
part of a team that
needs immediate and
impactful results,
you can enter into
the challenge.
Other than bragging rights,
you can win $25,000 of credits
in GCP, which is a grand sum.
And then you can get a
CCP license for a year.
OK, so I'm going to
go into the demo, so--
OK, so what I'm going to
show you first is CCP,
and you can see that I've
got tenant clusters already
deployed.
Now, let's make sure--
because I mentioned that
there is a VMware component,
I'm going to open
up VMware, and we'll
see if we can
visualize that for you.
But one of the things
that is unique to CCP
is that we do upgrades, right?
So it's automated.
You don't have to
get in line to it.
You basically choose what it
is that you want to upgrade,
whether it's the control plane
itself or the tenant plane.
And then we do the
automation for it, right?
So the reason why
I mention upgrades
is because all of us who have
interacted with Kubernetes
knows that when you--
kubelet does not
suffer an IP change.
It just doesn't.
It doesn't suffer
through it, right?
So if you change
the IP, then you'll
have issues with your
upgrade because the API
server won't come up.
So the way that we deal with
this is to provide a VIP IP,
right?
So the VIP IP is assigned
to an API server,
and then, the attributes
of the existing cluster
are going to be retained
when you upgrade, right?
So we give network
administrators and operators
the ability to define their own
networks and their own pools.
And then, I mentioned
that we today
have integration into VMware.
That's our
infrastructure provider.
We're going to make this
compatible with OpenStack
and also bare metal
in the future.
And then, as far as Active
Directory is concerned-- so
we assume that our
enterprise customers already
have an existing
authentication provider.
So you'll see that this
is already authenticated.
And then, all you
need really here
is just a distinguished name.
And of course, it runs
over TLS securely.
And then, you define
which AD groups you want.
And then, we automatically query
those AD groups for the users,
and we allow them to
log into CCP, right?
So probably, this is kind of
one of those table stakes.
But certainly, SSO and
mutual authentication
and just integration into
an existing authentication
provider is something
that is challenging
for doing Kubernetes manually,
and then doing it consistently.
So we'll walk through
that three-step process
that I was talking about, right?
And we actually won't
deploy a cluster
because I'm going to do
it with an API, right?
OK, so here, we're
basically choosing
the attributes of a
typical VMware environment.
And the thing about
the networking layer
is that you can choose--
let's say the Contiv CNI--
and you can still operate
the Contiv CNI cluster
inside of an ACI fabric.
So there are a lot of choices.
It just depends on the
underlay and overlay options
that you want to choose.
And then, all I'm
walking through here
is just the different
options that you have.
So we're going to
keep this standard.
And then, the reason
for the username
is because we'll inject--
we'll create the user
name and inject the key
so that when the users
want to directly interact
with the nodes, it's going to be
delivered by an SSH key and not
a password.
All right, so you get
all these options.
And then, this is basically--
that was the three
screens, and this would
be the fourth screen, right?
So what I'm describing
to you is a reduction
of the complicated logic that
initially would apply to doing
Kubernetes on your own, right?
Now, imagine that you can
offer this as service catalog
to multiple users.
When you do this, obviously you
can apply a governance model
around that, right?
OK, so I'm going to go back.
And let's say that I want to
interact with this cluster,
right?
So I have the option
to upgrade, but I
won't upgrade because I don't
have the tenant image for that.
I'm going to download the token.
OK, so we'll see here that's
the token name, right?
OK, so what I'm going to do is--
all right, so basically
what I did was--
in order for me to
interact with my cluster,
I have to run kubectl, right?
In order for me to
run kubectl, have
to define at least
a config file,
and this is basically
that config file, right?
So this is the representation
of that cluster
that I saw in the UI.
So what I'm showing you
is a seamless and easy way
for consumers as well
as administrators
to interact with the
assets that they deploy.
OK, so I'll show
you that these are
all the different namespaces.
And if we take a look at this--
I may be going through
this too quickly,
but it's basically
the same cluster.
That's what I'm proving to you.
Every control plane has a
Swagger interface, right?
So this is kind of the
design-first approach
to providing a
consumable platform.
So you can look at all the
different operations, right?
And let's open it up.
And if you haven't
used Postman before,
it's just a tool that allows
you to interact with APIs.
So I'm going to get a token.
I'm going to do a
get for the clusters,
and then I see all the
different clusters.
So I'm going to do
a Create Cluster.
All right, so hopefully
you can see that I'm
naming it Google Next 18 TBN.
So we do not have a
cluster with such name.
And now, hopefully we'll see
that it starts to show up.
So it's going to take a
while to provision, more time
than we have.
But the point here is that you
can easily interact with it
through APIs, all right?
So one of the things that I
wanted to show very quickly--
now again, this is the
Cloud Center product that
is one of the pillars in
the Hybrid Cloud Platform--
is not a part of CCP, right?
So I just want to make it clear
that what I'm showing you--
Cloud Center-- is not
a component of CCP,
but it'll show you how--
it's one thing for a
developer or someone
to just interact with the
cluster using kubectl, right?
Very, very difficult for
you to apply a governance
model around it.
I won't let this
distract us too much.
So basically, what
I was going to show
you is that Cloud Center is
a multi-cloud application
delivery and application
lifecycle management tool,
right?
So what I was going
to show you is,
hey, instead of allowing
users to just go to Kubernetes
and do a kubectl command
to add a new namespace
or to delete a namespace
or to create Istio
or to install the
service catalog,
you would develop
these different service
catalog items, right?
So you would present
them in the catalog,
and then what you could
do is apply an RBAC model
to the privileges to
those assets, right?
So only certain people would
be able to do it, right?
And of course, because of Cloud
Center's agnostic nature, what
happens is you only have to
develop that service once,
right?
And then, that
service conceivably
could be executed on
any of the environments
that Cloud Center
supports, right?
And if you don't know
about Cloud Center,
it's quite broad in--
it has a very rich
integration ecosystem
as far as clouds are concerned.
All the public
clouds that you can
think of, as well as
many OpenStack variants--
and of course, we showed VMware.
[MUSIC PLAYING]